evergrand is the world's most indebted
real estate firm and it's been flooding
its social media accounts with videos
like this
showing that the company is back to work
meanwhile buyers and real estate
vloggers are also taking to social media
to complain about construction delays or
that they haven't received their new
homes the wall street journal examined
these posts to understand why people are
upset even as evergrande has been trying
to fulfill pledges it has made to
regulators to deliver more than one
million pre-sold homes
if the company can't meet its
obligations consumer confidence could
tank rippling through the chinese
economy and potentially impacting the
global economy it has definitely turned
from being that prestigious developer
giant into something that everyone's
concerned about so we compare social
media posts from people waiting for
homes they've already paid for and once
from evergrand as it promises to do
whatever it takes to deliver them
but first here's how one of china's
largest property developers ended up
with so many stalled construction sites
pandemic lockdowns had hurt the
company's sales and new government rules
kept it from borrowing more money
then this past summer evergrant said it
was experiencing a cash crunch and
construction at many of its 778 projects
in 233 cities were halted all across
china the company has offices and many
have their own social media accounts on
wechat one of the country's most popular
messaging apps we looked at content
published by 20 of them between
september and november
most of the posts follow a similar
pattern first the company says it's
working hard to deliver homes and resume
construction
then there are either videos or photos
of workers returning to empty project
sites
and testimonials from buyers who've
signed contracts to move into their new
homes
these homeowners are among the many
urban chinese who plowed their savings
into new homes collectively they have
nearly 78 of their wealth tied up in
residential property the property market
in china is
very important to its economy real
estate activity accounts for roughly
one-fourth of china's gdp and essential
concern for the government is making
sure that people get the properties that
they paid for
economists and real estate agents in
china say there's a lot at stake
evergrand has an estimated 1.4 million
pre-sold apartments outstanding and if
they aren't finished many households
could suffer painful losses shaking
confidence in the country's property
market and a downturn in the world's
second largest economy could spread to
other countries trying to bounce back
from the pandemic so evergren has to
make this their priority as well and the
best way to deliver the flats is to find
ways to resume construction local
authorities are also helping out the
company most of the cities with
evergrand projects have set up task
forces to help manage the process and
hired accountants to comb through their
finances
in early november evergrant said it had
handed over more than 57 000 homes
between july and october these
announcements can give a bit of hope to
buyers who are in a desperate situation
of having poured so much money into
these unfinished apartments they bought
this is probably just the beginning of
this colossal process to restart
constructions at these unfinished sites
and many many more are still waiting for
their homes and some of those waiting
have been using various social media
platforms to vent their frustration we
looked at 20 posts from buyers who said
that construction appeared stalled or
doubted they would move into their new
homes on schedule i do want to point out
that some buyers have expressed relief
on social media about finally getting
their homes and that others also have
complained about water and gas leaks
or even unfinished interiors and people
have seen empty construction sites so
how the company is going to turn around
will be scrutinized by people because
this involves something as intimate and
as important to them as their homes
evergreen has promised homebuyers to
deliver what they have paid for but
there are also unfinished buildings with
apartments that haven't been sold and a
lower priority for the company we looked
at posts from real estate vloggers who
review property sites and provide
investment tips and they've been doing
their own inspections of evergrand
projects
honda this footage was filmed by real
estate vlogger hupeichi she went to this
site called evergrand city in hohad
inner mongolia in november
a month earlier the company posted
photos of evergrand city and some more
than 1400 apartments across six
buildings have been finished
this footage shows that about a month
after that announcement evergrand city
had other buildings waiting to resume
construction
evergrant says it's working with the
government and in early december the
government of guangdong the province
where the company is based said it will
send a working group to help the
developer work out its problems and
maintain normal operations evergrand has
around 20 billion dollars worth of
outstanding dollar bonds and it's
managed to avoid defaulting on them by
making last minute interest payments on
deadline
for this video the company declined to
respond to requests for comment on
specific instances of delay construction
the poor quality of some finished homes
and whether the company was aware of
complaints on social media so until the
homeowners get the keys to the
apartments they bought they have social
media to share their concerns with
others and check on the progress of
their homes